ضخم تحت سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه لكن ما
هي اهميه هذه المدينه التي حاولت روسيا
سيطره عليها منذ بدايه الحرب تقع باخ
متعلى ضفتين نهري بخموتوكا شماليه مقاطعه
اليونيس في اقليم جمباز شرقي اوكرانيا
وتبعد نحو 600 كم عن العاصمه كيف تعد بخمه
بالنسبه للاوكرانيين للدفاع عن المدن
منطقه
فمنها توجه ضربات للمواقع الروسيه بما في
ذلك مدينه دنيتك عاصمه المقاطعه وهي هامه
الروس بعد خسارتهم مدينه الزوم جنوب منطقه
خفيف في شهر سبتمبر اصبحت بخمه البوابه
الجنوبيه الشرقيه
اضافه الى كونها عقده مواصلات هامه يمر
فيها خط حديدي يربط جنوب وشرق حوض دنياك
بالغرب والشمال الاوكرانيه اخيرا تشكل
باخمته واحده من اكبر مراكز الصنا الاله
الثقيله في اوكرانيا كما انها تساهم بنحو
30% من الملح الصخري في البلاد